now it's the fourth night of Hanukkah
and in honor of the holiday guess who's
here once again this year Rabbi Levi
harling with Shabbat of Southern Nevada
talk about the meaning of Hanukkah and
of course we also have uh latkes and
jelly donuts as well we've got it all
here Rabbi it's good to see you once
again this year thank you for having us
always a pleasure to be on the show and
happy Hanukkah and to you as well so
let's talk about uh the story of
Hanukkah sure so story took place a
little bit over 2 000 years ago Jews
were under Greek Syrian Rule and they
came up with some harsh decrees for
bidding us from keeping our religion
practicing our traditions two miracles
of the Hanukkah story Miracle number one
the Jews formed a small army called the
makamis although they were small in
number they were victorious in battle
over the mighty Greek Syrian Army
Miracle number two they come back to the
temple clean it up because it was
desecrated destroyed by the Greek
syrians they wanted to light the menorah
they searched for some pure olive oil
now the one little drug which is only
enough to last for one day but I believe
in God as you know they let the menorah
had a lasted for eight nights and eight
days therefore you celebrate Hanukkah
for eight nights and eight days and a
lot of the traditional food focuses
around the oil because of the miracle of
the oil speaking of which let's talk
about some of the the traditions of of
Hanukkah that you've brought with you
we've got the menorah in front of us of
course and then on the table here we've
got uh the latkes which are crucial to
any solid celebration exactly so potato
Latka is deep frying in oil jelly donuts
custard donuts chocolate vanilla
whatever you want deep fried oil again
to celebrate the miracle of the oil it's
really a time to gather through family
spend some time to recognize and
understand it was the victory of good
over evil and we can all be like the
menorah be a beacon of light out into
the world we have the menorah kits for
those that don't have a menorah candles
inside there we've got the chocolate
coins also about education so we give
gifts to the children we have the
dreidels and the dreidels of course
which are you know part of the part and
parcel of Hanukkah let me see are you
familiar with the story adrenal story
let's hear it again real quickly so
dreidel has four four Hebrew letters
during the time of the decree the
children were not able to study the
Bible couldn't study the total but they
would go out into the caves and secretly
study when the Greek syrians would
approached they would hide their Scrolls
and say oh no we're just we're just
playing a game of drill as a cover-up
for their studies so we play a dreidel
it's a competitive game play with your
family play with adults like to play
with real guilt real money children play
with the chocolate coins I love that
finally before we go here are some of
the celebrations happening around
there's so many of them of course uh
what's going on for the rest of Hanukkah
we got some we got me my dancing
dreidels we'll see a little bit soon all
over Vegas today we'll be at Henderson
hospital we'll be at the Clark County
Commissioner's Office later this evening
silver Knights tomorrow okay there's a
menorah parade with car top Menorah down
the strip Saturday night there's a
concert on Sunday in The Plaza Hotel all
over Vegas we're here to celebrate bring
the Hanukkah message out to the public
and coming up later here in Good Day Las
Vegas Yes you asked for it we've got it
again the dancing dreidels world famous
and they may be joining them as well
good to see you once again happy
Hanukkah to you